hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
and Ashley ed nur here from the YouTube
channel how to's and Morgan and Ashley
great YouTube channel with this lovely
face of and personality I've known
Ashley for like 14 years and she's the
first lady guest of the channel this
video today 82 year old man covers
drowning pool for America's Got Talent
one of our reward tiers on patreon is
whatever video you request we must
definitely do and put up on YouTube
whether it be a discussion or reaction
this is a reaction requested by none
other than film reviewer Andrew Hayes
who normally wants film-related content
to be talked about but now he wants us
to talk about this one right here this
is I think it's um drowning pools bodies
on America nothing wrong with me -
nothing wrong with me that the bodies
hit the floor right it's let the bodies
hit the floor
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
sounds like and what's your name sir
John heffinger way from Joe I'm from
Broomfield Colorado I'm Jonas my memory
how do you I am 82 years old no you
don't look a day over 90 yes I retired
about 15 years ago that's about the time
I started doing karaoke before you
retire what was your job the most recent
one was aerospace engineering did you go
to space I was a Navy pilot that was far
enough into cities battery loves them
out CBS talent why be to come on the
show to know you expect
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh she is not impressed
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow hey you should have sent over the
video where you have their opinions on
it maybe we could find it on it's gotta
be somewhere it's gotta be somewhere
right yeah okay okay hold on oh here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I was not expecting now anyone yeah I
actually got a little bit scared yeah
your face like totally changed you like
is there like a mosh pit where you work
there's a lot of beer I thought you were
gonna come on and sing flying me to the
moon love you John Wow okay we're gonna
have to vote yes
[Applause]
[Music]
lady for me to know I'm sorry
[Laughter]
and those that like you I have to agree
I have to agree with how Ian Meldrum is
cover of the song exactly he's 82 he's
up there doing he's got a respectable
last career and the fact that he just
surprised and totally won the hell out
of the crowd over and he just said that
this was like the highlight of like his
life basically like how sad would that
have been - what's with the stick up
your ass Heidi the guy like the surprise
factor alone makes it on automatic
Whitney just because you don't expect
some old ass dude to do this I don't
know if you're playing an actual
heavy-metal man but like in karaoke
oh god performance the guy's committed
as [ __ ] there's something like weirdly
sweet about it so cute I wonder like
when he goes to karaoke nights like if
he does if this is his go-to song yeah
or through her actual songs he can he
can really sing like a fly me to the
moon or baby this is just the kind of
music he's really drawn to yeah maybe
what a sweet old man oh thanks yeah the
crowd loved it and that's what should
count most yeah I'm Heidi's own self
involved opinion on the matter I don't
think a different outfit there so he he
came back yeah if you pass you go back
yes I wonder if he did the same song I
don't know maybe maybe well man Andrew
Hayes dude this guy your grandpa or
something why'd you recommend his seven
Oh that'd be cool thanks for tuning in
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click notification bells
Ashley ender is on Instagram I follow
her and she has her own YouTube channel
that I'm subscribed to so you should
subscribe to make sure
- yes right I've been in a couple of
videos I teach them how to pole dance
that's right we go to him for no comment
but um
[Laughter]